Vénus dans tous ses états c'est le nom
d'un colloque qui va débuter demain au
Palais de la Découverte coloc organisé
par l'Université de Versailles 50 ans on
Yvelines ce sera à Paris devant le
public bonsoir Jenny et gerdino vous
êtes donc maître de conférence à
l'Université de Versailles 50 ans vous
pilotez notamment ce colloque un
colloque inter disciplinaire on ne
parlera aussi bien de la planète que de
la figure dans la mythologie de Vénus
pourquoi ce colloque interdisciplinaire
déjà parce qu'il est organisé par des
étudiants d'une filière d'une formation
interdisciplinaire qui associe les
sciences les arts la culture
les technologies multimédia et puis la
médiation des savoirs parce que sont des
étudiants qui pilotent aussi
l'organisation c'est parti de leur
formation alors c'est eux qui montent
toute l'organisation du colloque qui
réfléchissent aux thématiques des tables
rondes qui sont organisées bien entendu
qui sont suivis par un certain nombre
d'enseignants de l'équipe d'enseignement
de ce master professionnel d'ingénierie
de la Culture et de la Communication et
parmi eux deux personnes clés qui sont
Thomas Widman et Isabelle brianso qui
ont vraiment suivi l'organisation de
l'opération elle-même on a découvert
l'affiche de ce colloque qui débute
demain pourquoi le choix de Vénus aussi
parce que Thomas Widman est planétologue
et a proposé ce thème qui rassemblait
les sciences les arts la culture la
connaissance la diffusion
toute la disciplines le cinquième rêver
parce que c'est un objet scientifique
très intéressant Vénus en tant que
planète donc c'est intéressant
planétologue c'est intéressant au sens
où c'est une planète qui ressemble
d'assez près à la terre qui n'a pas bien
entendu toutes les caractéristiques loin
sont faux mais qui présente des systèmes
atmosphériques assez particulier qui
peuvent renseigner aussi sur des
situations climatologiques qui sont les
nôtres par exemple les chercheurs s'y
intéressent toujours beaucoup justement
à cette planète
ici intéresse toujours et puis il y a
aussi ces procédures d'occultation
plus qui est passé devant le soleil il y
a quelques temps et qui renseigne aussi
les scientifiques parce que c'est un
moyen de détecter ce qui s'appelle les
exoplanètes c'est à dire les planètes
ressemblant à notre terre mais qui se
trouve très loin et qu'il faut détecter
avec des instruments bien entendu
extrêmement précis extrêmement sensible
imaginez qu'une exoplanète regarde
arrivé à voir une exoplanète c'est
essayer d'observer depuis ici une orange
qui se trouve à Marseille et sur
laquelle la bien entendu c'est la
porteuse d'oxygène il y a certainement
de l'eau et qui aurait l'équivalent
d'une goutte d'eau répandue à sa surface
donc imaginez la difficulté donc des
planètes telles que Vénus beaucoup plus
proches de nous bien évidemment que les
exoplanètes une planète comme celle-ci
on connaît tes caractéristiques mais
aussi peaufiner les instruments
d'observation lorsqu'elle
occulte un astre comme le soleil
pour ses exoplanètes qui peuvent
graviter autour d'un d'une étoile ça
peut être intéressant bien évidemment ça
a l'air très pointu très scientifique
mais c'est ouvert au grand public aussi
oui alors la manif est complètement
ouverte au grand public puisque chaque
année nous organisons et ça fait la
neuvième du genre nous organiser une
manifestation des 7 ordre là sur deux
jours et qui réunit quatre tables rondes
une part de mes journées bien entendu
c'est le 9e coloc organisé donc par ses
étudiants de l'université de Versailles
50 ans dans le cadre de leur formation
c'est la première fois que vous vous
intéressez à ce cas de Vénus pourquoi
Vénus fait aussi autant rêver peut-être
fantasmé je parle aussi bien de la
figure antique que de la planète la
femme avant tout peut-être mais bon la
mythologie aussi et puis
les 1000 à une représentations de Vénus
en peinture en sculpture dans les écrits
aussi la littérature donc on développe
on essaye de développer cette rencontre
autour de plusieurs catables rondes ou
plusieurs thématiques scientifiques
artistiques et culturel fictionnelle
aussi la fiction l'imaginaire collectif
et puis habituellement aussi une table
ronde autour d'éducation c'est que
fait-on de ses savoirs là et comment les
communiquer on va parler de l'art
justement on a parlé de la planète Vénus
et justement cette planète qui fait
rêver aimeriez-vous la visiter ou quel
autre planète aimeriez-vous
réveillerez-vous de visiter c'est notre
question du jour micro-trottoir la lune
parce qu'il y a déjà quelques personnes
qui sont allées dessus et ça peut être
sympa
être en apesanteur
de la vie sur Mars
moins loin et a priori ça va devenir
accessible un jour elle a la planète
Terre il y a plein de choses à découvrir
encore sur splender en fait Jupiter on
dit que c'est du gaz
ce que ça donne là-bas
et puis c'est la plus grosse des
planètes il me semble
franchement je crois qu'elles sont
toutes intéressantes après si toute la
difficulté bien entendu on a entendu la
terre aussi dans le micro-trottoir
effectivement
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
qui organise donc ce colloque
interdisciplinaire autour de Vénus sur
oublier de la terre et aussi figure
féminine deux journées sur ce colloque
la première partie qui est plus portée
sur la science véritablement sur la
planète et puis l'autre partie sur l'art
on va découvrir justement cette figure à
travers les âges et les représentations
à travers les âges encore actuelle
fictionnelles aussi et puis
effectivement la femme qui fait rêver
peut-être qui interviendra pour ces
différents colorants je n'ai plus
l'ensemble des noms en tête il y a au
moins au minimum 16 enseignants parlons
ces chercheurs qui sont spécialistes à
la fois de de
planétologie d'histoire de littérature
d'art donc il y a des chercheurs de
différentes universités de différents
pôles du monde entier même de l'Europe
en tout cas l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin aussi sera représenté il y
a des chercheurs qui plongent
actuellement aussi bien sur cette figure
antique que sur la planète des
chercheurs qui plongent en termes
d'Histoire et puis en termes de
représentation aussi et ces chercheurs
travaillent au quotidien avec ses
étudiants pour établir un petit peu le
carnet de route de l'organisation de
cette manifestation parce que j'imagine
que les étudiants qui doivent organiser
on le rappelle se sont eux qui pilotent
ce colloque doivent aussi un petit peu
se tenir au fait au courant des
différentes avancées alors si toutes les
difficultés effectivement c'est de ne
pas être un maître en l'espèce mais en
même temps d'arriver à construire une
une contribution comme celle-là donc
effectivement de ce documenter et puis
d'orchestrer l'ensemble de la
manifestation y compris les supports
iconographiques tout ce qui est
communiqué de presse aussi qui fait
savoir qui fait connaître et puis aussi
de s'assurer que le discours qui va être
donné par des spécialistes un discours
intelligible pour le public il y aura un
compte rendu et donc pour ceux qui nous
en l'espèce on ne le fait pas quelques
rares occasions on a monté des
rencontres avec le son du patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO a du reprise
d'ailleurs donc là c'était l'objet
effectivement d'une rencontre
internationale qui nécessitait ou si un
support et moins des traces il y a des
enregistrements c'est le lock mediapoli
sur les nouveaux médias que nous avons
organisé l'année dernière et toujours
sur l'Internet de l'université et vous
pouvez regarder visionner les tables
rondes qui ont qui ont pris place lors
de ce Collot qui débute mardi il y a un
site internet il va s'afficher à nouveau
sur votre écran si vous souhaitez en
savoir plus parler de la découverte
rendez-vous à partir de demain mardi
jusqu'à mercredi vous nous le redites ça
s'adresse au grand public pour ceux qui
auraient peur justement c'est l'objectif
c'est l'objectif et ce sont les
étudiants qui le pilotent c'est
l'occasion de juger un petit peu de leur
travail aussi puisque ça fait partie de
leur formation Merci à VOUS 16 et 17
avril et le site internet pour en savoir
plus